We're asked to simplify the cube
route of 8a squared b to
the fifth c to the
third power.
Now the easiest way to simplify
a cubic radical like
this, where you have to find
the cube root, is to factor
this expression inside the
radical into things that are
perfect cubes and things
that aren't.
And the things that are perfect
cubes, we can just
take the cube roots of those and
then kind of take them out
of the radical.
And everything else we
can leave under it.
So first let's just focus on the
8, figure out if it can be
factored into a perfect cube, or
if it maybe it's a perfect
cube itself.
8 is 2 times 4.
4 is 2 times 2.
So 8 is 2 times 2 times 2.
Or it's 2 to the third.
2 to the third is equal to 8.
Or we could say that the cube
root of 8 is equal to 2.
So 8 is already a nice,
perfect cube.
So let's worry about this
other stuff over here.
So let me rewrite the radical.
Let me rewrite the radical
over here.
I'll leave the 8 the way it is
because it's a nice, perfect
cube already.
I'll leave the 8
the way it is.
And then, let me focus-- well,
a squared, I'm not going to
really be able to factor that
into kind of a to the third
times something else.
I mean I could if I wanted to
be really tricky, but I'll
just leave it as a
squared for now.
Let me do that in a
different color.
So that's a squared.
Put a squared.
b to the fifth, I can write that
as b to the third power
times b squared.
And that way I have a perfect
cube here and then I have
something that's not.
But this, at least, I could
take the cube root of.
And then, c to the third.
That's already a perfect cube.
c to the third, the cube
root of that is c, so
times c to the third.
And so we can rewrite this
expression here, just
reordering things
a little bit.
This is the same thing as the
cube root of 8-- that's the
first term right there-- times
the cube root of b cubed times
the cube root of c cubed.
So, so far I've taken care
of that term, that
term, and that term.
And these are all of the ones
that I can actually take the
cube root of.
And I can leave the other two
under this larger cube root.
So times the cube root of-- we
have our a squared here and
then our b squared.
Our a squared and then we have
a b squared right here.
Now, the cube root of 8 is 2.
The cube root of b to
the third is b.
Let me do it in the same colors,
makes it more visually
compelling.
Cube root of c to
the third is c.
And then this, you can't really
simplify anymore.
I mean you could kind of play
around with it, but this is
about as simplified as you can
get for this cubic radical, or
this cube root radical, or this
third root, depending on
how you view it.
So, times the cube root of
a squared b squared.
And we're done.